Today's lecture is what have we learned in entrepreneurship for the last 40 years.
One of the interesting questions is why are you here?
I hope you're here to find out what does it take to go from an idea to a business.
For the last 20 years if you wanted to know how to go from an idea to a business,
the answer from educators and investors are simply, "Well, go research and then write
a business plan and you'll know everything possible to actually start and run your business."
We now know that advice was simply wrong--not kind of wrong but very wrong.
We now today know something we didn't know before.
We now know the right way to build startups and so this class is about that right way,
but before we get started, let's see how we took the wrong path
and then see what we now know worse.